- Hi everyone, thank you.
My name's Michael Webster.
I'm a principal engineer at CircleCI
and we're gonna talk a little bit today
about kind of where we
are right now with agents
and what they're doing to the SDLC.
Some of the problems
that we're seeing already being created,
and some techniques we're
finding effective to fix it.
I'm including some things
we're adding into our product.
So yeah, let's go and get started.
As a quick recap, I wanna
go over sort of like,
kind of the history of agentic workflows.
I won't go too in-depth,
but I think kind of where we are now
is starting to see a little
bit of a decoupling point
that we didn't have, right?
So back in the days of 2021, 2022,
there was a lot of developer copy-pasting
between terminal IDE, a
ChatGPT window, what have you.
Then we start seeing IDEs come
along that are still driven
by the developer, but are
capable of more agentic tasks.
They can do more long-range
planning and execution.
This was really interesting,
unlocked a lot of potential
within the AI space.
But now what we're seeing
is these sort of headless agents
starting to emerge, right?
You take a CLI, you throw it
inside of a Docker container,
and now suddenly you can
start running cron jobs,
webhook-triggered agent runs,
anything you really like,
in order to impact this.
Now, there's a lot of
products on the market
they've launched in the
last six months to do this,
and so I thought it was interesting
to maybe take a look and see
how real is this trend, right?
So I went through and I looked
at all of the bot activity
in the public GitHub archive,
going back to the end of last year.
And just sort of looked into like,
for these known coding agents,
a small subset of them, five or six,
what are they actually doing on GitHub?
And you can see a normal
sort of like really rapid
growth trend overall
within these agents across, you know,
all the big common ones, Copilot,
Claude, Codex, all of those.
But it gets more interesting.
So there's obviously some growth,
there's activity from these agents.
But it gets more interesting
when you break it down
into the event types.
Like what are these agents actually doing?
And you start to see a
really interesting trend
from the first like three
months on and then forward.
When these things first launched,
they were just doing PR comments.
This was just like code review bots,
every example starter workflow
of how to use an agent
and an action or in a CircleCI config.
It was doing things like issue triage
and code review, and that's what they did.
But you can see around May
of this year, you started
to see these agents actually
starting pushing code, right?
This was something that
people sort of expected,
but it took a little while to happen.
And at this point they're
almost doing as much.
This data is as recent as October,
in some weeks you're seeing
just as much push activity
as you are comment and PR activity, right?
So these agents are
actually doing real work.
They're pushing actual
code to real repositories,
which is what you would expect, again,
with the growth trends.
So that's public GitHub activity,
but that could simply be experiments,
people with hobbyist projects,
nothing necessarily like
in a real-world setting.
So at CircleCI, we see a lot
of build activity from multiple projects
that aren't on the public GitHub archive.
These are, you know, enterprises,
large and small startups.
So we decided to look and see
what does our activity pattern see?
Do we see a similar growth trend
as what we see in the public archive?
And this is a screenshot
kind of some aggregated
and anonymized data.
And you see, again, we see this trend,
we see the same pattern repeat itself.
So there's activity happening.
And in particular with CircleCI,
these are cases where we
actually ran a pipeline.
This is not a case where
someone simply updated a README
or maybe it was building a static blog.
This is someone took the
time to configure a pipeline
to run unit tests and do deploys
in response to a push event.
All right, so this is like,
you would think this is
economically valuable work
being done by these agents.
It's not just, I had a hobby
project, let me go turn on
and see if Claude can
keep my GitHub, you know,
activity green or something like that.
And again, this is all looking at agents
that we can distinctly identify.
So this is our low-end
estimate of what's happening.
If you use Claude Code or Codex or Kiro
and commit under your own name,
we're not gonna necessarily
be able to tell that it's you.
So this is sort of like
a very low-bar estimate,
and we've seen within really about five
or six months, we've seen
a very fast growth clip.
And this is reflecting in
the revenue of these tools
and just the general trends overall
where people are more willing to try out
these headless agent votes.
Okay, so why is this a problem?
Like, this is the thing
that everybody wanted.
We wanted these agents to
do more than just like,
get us out of the IDE.
Instead of multi-boxing cursor,
you can now just have multiple
agents running in parallel.
And the issue here really comes down to
the code isn't really valuable
until it's in a customer's hands.
And all of the stuff that
happens after you write the code
is not necessarily keeping up, right?
PRs are getting massive, open
source projects are requiring
AI disclosures because they
suddenly get mysterious
2000 line PRs that all look alike.
Reviews are taking longer,
humans looking at those 2000 line PRs
and in general, the build
stability isn't really improving.
And this is kind of what you would expect.
This is a basic kind of queuing theory.
It's a branch of math
about how queues operate.
To simplify it a lot,
really, if work is arriving
into your system faster than you're able
to process it, you get delays.
You probably understand this intuitively.
If you've ever been at a store
that only had a single checkout
line when they were busy,
everybody has to wait.
Eventually, some people
might get tired and give up,
but when we have, you know, a
revenue feature on the line,
we can't really just stop.
So the queue just builds up and builds up,
and then people stop working
to go drain the queue
and do all the reviews.
So the reality is for
a lot of organizations,
even though you can
write a lot of code now,
you probably couldn't
actually go much faster
if you wanted to in terms
of your delivery processes.
To give an example of
what this looks like,
I put together kind of
a queuing simulation
of under various scenarios what happens
with different speed-ups due to AI, right?
So, on the bottom, we kinda
have a status quo baseline.
It assumes that you can process code
twice as fast as you can write it.
But if you hold some of
these things constant,
as the AI gets faster and
faster, the delays get larger
and they come up even more quickly.
And this is particularly a problem
because with humans, the workday
ends at some point, right?
You don't have an infinite backlog
because people don't work
at an AI pace all the time.
But the agents can, if
you wanna hook them up
to your Jira backlog, your
linear queue, whatever,
whatever it is, the reality is
that for most organizations,
you're not actually gonna
be able to get the benefit
because you're gonna be
spending all your time reviewing
the PRs and waiting for
the deploys to go through.
This theory aligns with
subjective feedback.
You look at the DORA metrics,
there's actually some,
many teams are reporting an
increase in instability from AI.
There's minimal effects on
the product effectiveness.
And, in general, burnout.
If you look at other industry benchmarks,
when you dig in further, you
see that a lot of the AI gains,
they center around 10% improvement,
but that's widely distributed.
It's basically a bimodal distribution.
People who are really good
at delivering software
are getting most of the benefit.
People that are average to mediocre,
they're actually seeing no benefit
to negative effects from AI.
Okay, and this is a problem obviously
because like, you know, as a technologist,
we want these tools to work,
but also we're not putting
10% level improvements
from your senior engineer
investments into AI.
We're spending hundreds
of thousands to millions
of dollars building data
centers, all kinds of inference.
We need more than just
incremental improvements.
So how can we fix this?
Well, the simple pithy answer
is to go faster, right?
You know, in that
simulation I showed before,
we said like, okay, the
code comes in faster,
but the delivery goes the same.
Well, what if we just
made the delivery faster?
And you can see again,
expected effects here.
If you're able to ship the code faster,
the curve kind of bends down.
In some cases, even if you
don't get any improvement
from AI, if your agents
are still producing
at the same output as your developer,
but you've made your delivery faster,
you can actually cut your delays.
So this has benefit even
if you're using AI or not.
Okay, so we have a hypothesis
of how we can improve this.
We have some levers that
we think we can pull.
So what does it look like?
How do we actually do that?
Just go faster is not a
particularly actionable task.
To start with, like I
love AI, I love agents,
but I wanna be clear,
a lot of this isn't like whiz-bang
multi-agent orchestration.
Like it's block and tackling engineering,
like stuff we've been
doing for 15, 25 years.
You know, having things
like acceptance tests
that will reliably tell
you if things broke,
being confident that when you
get an automated PR from a
bot, whether it's a CDE bot
or an AI bot, that it didn't
cause a regression, right?
Where you're comfortable trusting the fact
that if your tests say
you're green, you're green,
and you can go ahead and merge.
You have to make investments
in your delivery pipelines.
And so I don't wanna
downplay all of this work.
This is all super necessary
and it's very tractable
and it's definitely a thing
that everyone should invest in.
AI's really great at helping
out with this too, right?
If you need to convert scripts,
if you've got a bunch of
bash scripts that are slow
and doing sub processing, you
can rewrite it in a language
that's compiled and the AI
will help you with that.
So it's definitely a spot
where AI benefits you,
but you do have to do this work.
Okay, but let's just assume
for the sake of argument
that's still not fast enough,
that only gets you, you know,
a slight reduction in your queuing delay.
Well, how can you go even faster?
And the way we think
about this at CircleCI is
that it really comes down to validation.
I'm riffing on a really old
saying about amateur stocking
strategy and professional
stocking logistics.
But the idea here is like instead
of obsessing about what's the latest
and greatest way to prompt an agent,
what's the latest and
greatest memory framework?
What have you.
Think about how you can
validate the code, right?
I'll try to make the case of
what I mean by validation here.
This is a really simple loop.
You make a plan, you do some work,
and you have something that
judges the quality of that work.
And then if it passes, you go through.
If it doesn't pass,
you go back to the beginning
and you start over.
This is the foundation of
if you wanna do
red-green-refactor, classic CI,
any type of like the local loops
that agents go through,
this is the pattern
that's really effective
at getting work done.
You do something, judge the results,
give feedback, and continue forward.
So this is the basic recipe
when we talk about validation.
To make a further argument
for why I think validation
is so important.
It has a lot of nice properties here.
It's really scalable, right?
So the work you put into
making sure that your code,
that you can validate
code written by agents,
it works for individual tasks, right?
You probably use a version
of this in your local loops
where Claude will run tests,
run linters, formatting.
It works if you want to
tune the prompts, right?
Having a set of, we know
this was a good change,
we know this was a bad change.
If you even want to go full on
like training your own RL agent,
the same, that basic recipe
I showed of task, output,
evaluate, and loop is really
the fundamental recipe.
So it works all the way
up from your developer
on your machine, all the way
up until you get to the point
where you're wanting to
train your own agent.
It's also durable, right?
If you've been in the AI space at all,
you're familiar with all of the churn,
it's chain of thought,
then it's graph of thought,
now it's program of thoughts.
Like, there's like,
there's so many techniques
that people learn and I'm glad
that people are researching them.
But for end developers,
what ends up happening is they get trained
into the underlying models.
So trying to chase sort of like techniques
and tactics, you need to do
that to some extent, right?
You want to use the tools
that are available to you,
but making that the
centerpiece of your strategy,
you can probably steer your investment
in more productive ways.
Finally, agents are more
tractable for most organize,
or validation is tractable
for most organizations.
It's possible, but not
straightforward to run
and train your own models,
but making your tests faster,
understanding why your deploys failed,
understanding what good code
review feedback looks like
so that you can give it
to the developers earlier.
This is all information
that's readily accessible.
It's happening inside
of your organizations.
You're probably using a
developer experience tool
that is mining this
to tell you subjective
feedback on your developers.
So when you look across all of the things
that you could do when it comes to agents
investing in how you
validate their output,
to me feels like the most effective
high ROI option that we have.
Okay, the other thing
that I would recommend
investing in is context, right?
So whenever we are dealing
with agents, one of the things
that you have to manage
is, what does it know?
What is it having to remember
and what is it having to parse through
in order to complete the task?
The nice thing about this, about context,
is your validation
pipeline becomes an input
for context for the agent.
Taking a log of having Claude Code work
on a backlog of tasks,
having another AI summarize
the results of that task,
and then you feeding that
back to improve the prompts,
the tools, the sub agents
that you might be using
is a really powerful technique.
So yeah, at the end of the
day, you might be changing
a prompt, but you're driving
this off of real feedback
that's tuned to your
organization and your code basis.
Very quickly when we talk about context,
there's a few levers
that I think are really
important that you can deal with.
You really kind of can
control the tools, the task,
or the prompting of the
agent, as well as the check.
Aort of, you know, this is
a very simple version of
what an agent does where
you give it a task,
it keeps looping until
it passes some standard.
I think this check,
I would recommend a
bottom up approach here.
Start with a check, then
use that as a way to improve
how you give tasks to the agent,
and then extract those things into tools
that the agent can use, right?
So you use that validation as a way
to ripple things back up until
you end up with a library
of things that you have
really good confidence
that the agent can use and
execute on effectively.
So I'll give kinda like a verbal version
of this basic recipe that we found
really effective on that CircleCI.
When we're working in
our development teams,
which is we use the
feedback from CI pipelines
or local testing runs to get the model
to produce the results we want.
Once we have a baseline, once we have a,
we know that this is good,
then we can start extracting
that process into rules to get the model
to do that all the time.
So instead of everyone
starting from scratch,
one person goes through the
process of how do I get a
Playwright-based flaky test
fixing process working?
And then we're able to use
that across all of our projects
to perform a specific task.
And then just like any library
development kind of process
that you might have done before,
once you've got a few one-off
encapsulated functions,
you can then turn those into
rules that are more abstract.
So it's taking the same
techniques that we approach
with software and just
applying them to the prompts,
all driven off of a clear indicator of
if what the agent did was good or bad.
All right, and so, yeah,
I'll talk about Chunk now.
So Chunk, this is our CircleCI,
the agent that we're working with CircleCI
that's built from the ground up
with most of these principles in mind.
The idea behind Chunk is to help make sure
that your software is always validated
and to make the process of
validating that software faster,
more reliable, more effective.
Chunk, we built this thing
very much validation first.
Anytime this agent touches
your code base, it's going
to execute your CI pipelines
to verify that it works.
This means you're getting feedback
from real environments
that you've already built.
You already know that this environment
and these commands are good enough to say
that this code can go to production.
And so we're just gonna reuse that.
There's no real need to
completely reinvent the wheel here
and have to think too much about hooks
or some other side process
of development flow.
You've already configured a way
to test and see if these things are good.
We also keep your
software production-ready.
The first thing we're doing
is going after flaky tests.
When it comes to delivery,
flaky tests are kind of the bane
of at least my existence.
When you have a change
that you know is good,
but you have a test that is unreliable
and can't always tell you
if something is good or bad,
that slows everything down.
It slows down humans,
it slows down agents,
it really grinds, it's
standing in the gears
to any kind of smooth delivery process.
We're also working on, you know,
things like improving code
coverage, which again,
is very useful context
for agents to understand
how files relate to each other
and how they're tested effectively
and just generally
handling a lot of the toil.
Nobody really likes
maintaining CI pipelines.
I work at a CI company.
I don't like writing YAML,
but agents are really
good at writing YAML.
So things like build optimization,
keeping your build fast.
These are all really, these
are all first class tasks
that we'll be adding into Chunk.
The other thing that Chunk does here,
because we have context on all
of the changes that occurred
and whether they were good or bad, right?
We can follow a change all the
way through from the commit
that came into GitHub to
was this change deployed,
merged, deployed, or
eventually rolled back.
We're able to build a
really good understanding of
how you can make an agent
work more effectively.
So instead of you having
to build your own loops,
your own feedback cycles,
your own RL environments,
we can take the results of your builds
and we can use them as feedback to further
to the agents in a more automatic fashion.
All right, so quick
recap and takeaways here.
The AI agent adoption trend
is quite real and growing.
This is not, we're kind
of out of the realm
of reviewing PRs or triaging issues.
These are writing real code.
What we're seeing today is
probably an underestimate
of reality, but it is a
real and growing trend.
We're seeing that this is
causing some negative impact
and definitely is not
uniformly beneficial.
Not all organizations are
getting the same results
from AI initiatives
that they would expect.
Also, hopefully I've convinced you,
investing in the delivery
process is a really good start
and a way to get going.
And that the validation
that you do in delivery
is the foundations of keeping
your agents fast and reliable.
Yeah, and so that's all
I have for you today.
If you want to talk to me more about Chunk
or see a demo, I'll be
hanging out in the back,
and then we're in Booth 1451 at CircleCI.
Great, thanks y'all.